hello everybody my name is markiplier
and guess what I'm all better and also
guess what the [ __ ] liar because I'm
sicker than I've ever been and also I
can hear the keyboards firing up right
now telling me number one I can predict
the future by the way I just looked down
the comments see there's a top three
comments here number one mark you silly
little [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you doing
out of bed
tuck yourself in and get some soup in
your whatever way you can shove it up
your butt for all I can love you also go
[ __ ] yourself foe go go [ __ ] yourself
literally like that I don't know why
they got a little rambling towards candy
number two Oh
markiplier was better number three a
really detailed thesis on why my math
was wrong in the last video about the
Sun exploding or some [ __ ] like that
literally all those words are typed out
I don't know why they don't know what
they're talking about and neither do I
know I put myself in like a 50/50 chance
of surviving no rip me whatever also I'd
say it's about a 50/50 shot of you guys
even surviving this video
considering my voice sounds like two
gorillas grinding up against each other
with a bunch of rocks in between their
butt cheeks prestonby's are on this this
has been a long-ass introduction hope
you enjoyed it now I'm gonna get to the
actual game that I'm gonna play which is
called higher/lower which may or may not
be more higher or lower entertaining
than what you just saw nailed it
I got that joke oh I'm on fire oh good
thing I get so much funnier when I'm
sick so now on to the game we have the
incredibly interesting choice between
Nicki Minaj did I explain this game I
have no goddamn idea I can't remember
what the hell I've done with my life but
Nicki Minaj versus the Bilderberg Group
I don't know what the Bilderberg Group
is but I'm marginally sure that is
probably more more popular than Nicki
Minaj's but alone so I'm gonna guess
lower well wouldn't you thunk tit it's
pretty dang low what is 12 Angry Men
have to do with goddamn anything it's
the Bilderberg Group 12 Angry Men
I must say hire miss price of their
summer I don't know and a lot of things
that I don't know
oh god how many people could possibly be
looking updates Jared no one after what
I've seen yeah that's not a lot of
people oh let me consult my brain
inventory could teacher-training be pop
possibly more popular than air pollution
huh I got a funcle' about that one real
hard
I got a tap into the deepest recesses of
my brain too deterministic if this is
[ __ ] lower wait no I meant that
slower than no that's not what I bet I
did this I guess I look stupid now but
it's not the case I was smart I just
thought about it backwards I thought it
meant even though in the previous two
I knew that air pollution was more
popular that's why I was trying to say
but in my mind when I was crafting up
the stupid [ __ ] that I was gonna say
I accidentally phone called it too hard
and I went all back flap words Paris
saint-germain
which has the equivalent searches to
Nicki Minaj for some reason that's an
astronomically high some guess low there
we go nice and low huh beauty salon
versus teenage pregnancy I don't know
why I had to pick that picture to put on
there
it's almost inappropriate thank God is
blurred I'm guessing and this is the
state of society thing not just me the
teenage pregnancy is searched Wow
very close horoscope there are a lot of
people that do that thing I don't but a
lot of people Wow Wow
that's more than Nicki Minaj Law School
[ __ ] off Bob doesn't care about you
anymore all right we're on a roll I
think we're gonna get it huh this is
oddly appropriate law school versus
corruption if yet meld the two together
it'd be unstoppable
unfortunately corruption desires her
trade I was dragged corruption versus
this guy I don't know now this all
depends on how popular this guy is a
football not
American football football football I'm
guessing whoever this guy is is pretty
cool I'm judging by the back of his head
and that awesome hairstyle that he's got
going on now if he just died that read
he might be incremental he marginally
cooler than me to a mouse key I'm best
OCO I know I'll go get I don't know a
simi lon
I'll Cogan just had some legal battles
just recently so I'm guessing that I
[ __ ] all right gently versus the
Houston Rockets I haven't seen a Jet Li
movie a long time but I'm pretty sure
based on my knowledge of sports that the
Austin Rockets is actually a thing so
yeah yeah uh-huh measure to say oh I
guess lower probably lower Wow why why
is schizophrenia John get the [ __ ] out
of here
I don't have the voice to yell at you
Australia versus tattooist Iowa gets
lower than the entire Wow that is low
okay higher I don't even do to question
it I know from random football people
they're pretty popular wall bar higher
everyone's whoa that's too many searches
Red Nose Day huh I don't know what the
hell that is I think I know Walmart
everyone does know Adolph nice good to
know that Adolf Hitler is more popular
than those the Houston Rockets recipes
vs. ate half Hitler that is coming down
to all the parents of the world looking
up cooking recipes and even grandparents
you better pull it out for me
I don't want to head off Hitler to be
more popular than recipes come on you
[ __ ] it world you [ __ ] it you [ __ ]
up you made bail off Hill or popular
again you done did [ __ ] it Parkinson's
versus carpenters what does that have to
do with anything
is that guy's last name carpenter that's
what I'm gonna guess
how about guesses higher cuz I'm a
winner Tom Hanks
you better believe he's more popular
than carpenters but marginally less
popular than Adolf Hitler the Great
Escape huh don't know what that is
probably a movie but I had to assume
anything
Popeye for is the Great Escape all
things that are probably old but I think
people know Popeye you Wow Popeye is
more popular than Adolf Hitler but
Taylor Swift's probably higher you got a
damn right metropolis I don't know it's
talking about lower yeah alright
Petropolis vs. piano yeah no yeah yeah
oh this is gonna be tough okay specific
person usually lower because it's not
that range about a big no one's looking
for over Rugby World Cup that's got to
be higher what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you no one likes rugby we'll get to
ten I want to get to ten I want to get
to ten
okay Superbowl definitely higher you
goddamn right nailed it
send him a Paradiso don't know why not
okay got it
food bar this had beer [ __ ] I [ __ ] it
it was in a different language
something's in a different language and
a [ __ ] the thing Arsenal for his
water polo sorry
that's a lot water polo old Walters oh
boy here we go
waterfall bears ball monitors don't know
what the [ __ ] the Bolton water Wow
just barely edged it Edward Snowden he's
pretty popular Naz Popular's good old
ate off Aris probably more popular ah
Jennifer Aniston is gonna be tough lower
goddamn it why is everyone looking up
Jennifer Aniston this [ __ ] I hate
this this is gonna be the one geocaching
versus the Salvation Army I don't know
what geocaching is but it got damn
popular apparently flatten it Brahma
bull [ __ ] that guy is popular I know
that Australian Open now as popular as
this guy why is the Australian Open
popular but the world rugby Cup
[ __ ] popular at bar Stevo I remember
there was some Rockets it was just
barely higher than that yeah it was I
know that who's Barry Manilow probably
pop no one gives a [ __ ] about Barry
Manilow oh I'll get you that girion for
his Kurt Angle again slower yeah okay
Kurt Angle Friz Alicia Keys Kurt Angle's
being sandwiched between two musicians
and he just can't withstand the pressure
he's like a rock and between the butt
cheeks of two gorillas grinding up
against each other sorry Stevie right
Carrie I love it
bring on the singer train I have a
general idea of who's for who was more
popular than who got it nailed it Truman
Show [ __ ] off Google huh I wonder it's
probably high but not as high as I
thought it would be I don't know what
Santander is what the [ __ ] is Santander
okay I've gotten a few Diana Ross verses
mass surveillance I wish I had some mass
surveillance to know what the [ __ ] these
answers were but I'm willing to bet
people aren't searching for that Oh was
about to
yeah probably phone calls just a little
bit more popular yeah
Chanel sure sure okay oz it won another
quality joke people aren't searching
that movie anymore oh [ __ ]
oh oh oh damn oh [ __ ] I did it yeah I'd
celebrate more but I still feel like
[ __ ] let's keep it rollin considering
not many people looked for tattooist I
doubt there's many people that need a
personal assistant but a bing bada bing
go got it
what about stonemason even the less
popular who needs a stonemason goddamn
no one that's right Real Madrid that
sounds popular I was right I was exactly
that much right sorry Martin
can't do you it's not as popular as Real
Madrid Melbourne Cricket Ground who
would be searching for something that
specific [ __ ] that no one that's right
I knew it I'm onto you now world war two
definitely popular if I know something
about good old 8:00 off he's a [ __ ]
popular
guy and he basically ran that [ __ ]
blacksmith no way Jose way less mr.
Bream's
people know what that is god I can't
yell I did it I did it I got 17 I'm the
best I'm the best there ever was
considering I've never seen anyone play
this game
I have no goddamn idea how I did so I'm
done for now I'm very tired and very
sick so I'm gonna actually go lay down
now if I'm not better by tomorrow I'm
legitimately gonna take a day off but
until then I need to provide you with
that sweet delicious content and all
these top-quality jokes and I'm doing so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
video bye bye